[Music]
do you ever wish you could meet cartoon
characters in the real world you are not
the only one because many artists
already untuned them with 3d animation
most of them are so weird that you would
run away screaming as soon as you see
them but there are also some characters
that we would love to see in our world
are you ready to see these creations
stay tuned to see if your favorite
cartoon character made our list if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're showing you 20 cartoon characters
reimagined as 3d animations Homer
Simpson when we first met the characters
from The Simpsons 28 years ago we never
asked any questions about their looks
but wait until you see what Homer
Simpson looks like as pixel Lew
reimagined him and you won't look at him
the same way ever again his eyes are so
big that it look like cue balls that you
use when you play pool he must have been
lying a lot because his nose is really
long and we don't understand what is
happening with his mouth but this is not
normal no need to create a live-action
TV show of The Simpsons
we love them as they are Maggie Simpson
Homer was not the best looking man but
we thought that his cute little daughter
would be prettier but no it seems like
this man married a blow-up fish when you
look at the baby they had together we
never clearly understood how Maggie's
hair was styled but now that we take a
look at it we won't let this baby play
with hair gel anymore at least compared
to her father she has eyelids so she
will be able to close her eyes but we
have to admit that we would like to see
real-life Maggie on TV if the Simpsons
ever make a Halloween special in 3d
animation she needs to be a part of the
show spongebob squarepants you've
probably already seen spongebob out of
the water in our world on the TV show
once he dries he looks just like a
simple sponge that we use to clean the
dishes but deviantART reserved a warner
imagined him in another way this time
you can see all the little details on
the sponge and he looks scarier his skin
isn't so bad but when you look at his
face you won't want to swim in the sea
ever again and his pants seem so
complicated to put on
look at how many belt loops there are
but there is at least one great thing
that can save spongebob his imagination
as long as he stays in an imaginary
world on TV then we are all safe
Squidward Tentacles and we haven't
forgotten SpongeBob's neighbor we know
what a squid looks like in real life but
what about this cartoon character
thanks to Heba T Nickerson we'll have
the chance to see what he looks like and
by the look of this picture
Squidward doesn't seem pleased that
someone reimagined him in 3d animation
with his greenish skin and big head he
looks more like an extraterrestrial than
a sea creature and we have to admit that
he looks a little bit old with his
wrinkles and saggy skin but don't tell
him we just can't keep ourselves from
looking at this picture weirdness is
always fascinating don't you think
Mickey Mouse when you think about the
real-life version of the Disney mascot
you think of a little mouse wearing
pants don't you but if you look at the
original drawing you'll see that Mickey
Mouse is not like any other why is his
face so pale an artist from how to be a
dad tried to explain this in his artwork
Mickey Mouse doesn't have any hair on
his face and it seems like he also
forgot to put on pants his shoes and his
gloves go dress up Mickey and try to
come back as a cartoon character if you
can Popeye the girls thought that they
would love to meet a strong sailor like
Popeye and the men wanted to be like him
but wait until you see how Rick Baker
imagined him and you could change your
mind he's a little older than you
thought he was after all his show
started in the 60s and we're in the 21st
century now you would expect him to grow
old at least a little bit but no matter
what it seems like he's eating a lot of
spinach because this man is still in
shape even if he is more than 80 years
old we think he would win at an arm
wrestling contest against us stitch this
creature from lilo and stitch is a
genetically engineered extraterrestrial
life-form but no matter where he came
from we love him to the moon and back we
all wished we could adopt him but you
will probably let him stay with lilo
when you see this picture from Boris
kiss Aliki in real-life experiment 66
looks more like a monstrous blue koala
but
is not a reason not to like him as long
as he doesn't bite us with his sharp
teeth this strange creature deserves a
lot of hugs by understanding what a
family is he will become a loving little
pet Smurf you know what other little
creature is blue a smurf and this time
we will be less afraid to go near this
funny creature as nate Hallinan
reimagined it if we see it in the forest
it seems to be much more inoffensive and
adorable this mushroom light creature
looks like a cute little mouse with the
body of a tiny child but their blue skin
is what makes them recognizable wherever
you are in the world what would you do
if you ever saw one in the forest we
would love to meet everyone in their
village as long as we pay attention to
where we are stepping Philip J fry
The Smurfs used to live in the Middle
Ages but what happened to those who live
in the future
in Futurama we are transported a
thousand years later we meet people that
are not completely human anymore
but even the ones who are born in our
time look kind of weird when you look at
how Miguel Miranda imagined fry his
tennis ball eyes are huge and his mouth
is pushed a little too much forward and
we don't know what his hair is made of
but he's probably not a natural redhead
maybe this is what happens when you're
frozen for 1,000 years Hubert J
Farnsworth we can't get enough of
Futurama so here is another character
from the TV series once again
Miguel Miranda reimagined him and it
seems like Farnsworth didn't change and
if we didn't know him better we would
think that he looks like a villain he is
the nose of a witch in the mouth of a
raven we also bet that his eyes are huge
underneath those glasses and even though
this artist is really talented it is so
strange to think that we never realized
that our favorite characters look so
strange or maybe this is simply what we
will all look like at more than 160
years old
Jessica Rabbit if there is one female
cartoon character that we would like to
meet in real life it is Jessica Rabbit
this femme fatale is the woman all the
men want and all the girls want to be
but by looking at this picture from
pixel Lu week
ALPA realize that these are truly
unrealistic beauty standards her waist
is so thin that she could break into she
must have had a lot of plastic surgery
to look like that and we think that
Jessica maybe got a little too much of a
facelift around her eyes no matter what
we are lucky that she still lives in the
cartoon world we wouldn't want this
beautiful and irresistible woman to
steal our men Montgomery burns we
wouldn't mind if this character stayed
in the cartoon universe either no one
would like this greedy man to be our
boss and tell us not to forget that we
are here forever
but at least this time mr. burns looks
less scary than the members of the
Simpson family his skin is so saggy that
his nose will touch the ground in a few
years but we have to congratulate him
for brushing his teeth twice a day for
so many years because they look great or
maybe they're just dentures no matter
what we wouldn't dare to ask this man
seems to have found the elixir of life
and he wants to keep his secret safe
Peter Griffin
here's another member of a family that
we can't stop watching on TV the
characters from Family Guy look more
realistic than those we see in the
Simpsons we think that Peter will look a
little less strange right let's take a
look at how deviantART artist Matt Olien
RJ reimagined him the first thought that
we have when we see him is that he looks
like a potato with his round face
without a neck and he's looking at us
like we're a chicken that he would like
to eat which terrifies us just a little
bit but just look at his tiny ears and
they'll make you laugh Stewie Griffin
when Peter is there the toddler is not
far from him that is because Stewie
wants to get rid of Lois so beware if
you see him in real life this baby might
be after you and you should not
underestimate him as a 3d animation by
pixel ooh Stewie still has a big head in
the shape of a football he needs a lot
of space in his mind for all those
Machiavellian ideas and with his
enormous eyes he will be able to see
everything that happens around him this
is one toddler that no one would like to
babysit Buzz Lightyear you wouldn't
think that you would be interested in a
toy but Buzz Lightyear from Toy Story is
one a handsome man
just look at this artwork from the
talented Ray Oni Neary he looks like a
warrior ready to save the universe and
win our hearts this time the Space
Ranger hero has a much more realistic
look it looks almost like a picture if
you could date one cartoon character in
real life who would it be
don't forget to tell us in the comments
below we'd love to know more about what
you think Pikachu everyone wish that
they could catch a Pokemon and make them
their best friend and we actually did a
year ago when we all started playing
Pokemon go but just take a look at this
artwork from color bleed we still want
to meet Pikachu but we would like to
live in a cartoon universe instead of
seeing him in our real life universe
this enormous yellow rat looks quite
scary and aggressive and when we take a
look at his tail we don't understand how
nature could have shaped it this way we
would rather see them as cuddly little
creatures than dangerous monsters don't
you agree Fred Flinstone do you want to
know what men looked like thousands of
years ago no this one doesn't look like
a monkey but you'll see that evolution
had a lot of work to do since that time
here is Fred Flintstone as deviant
artists hannah and Barbara imagined him
it seems like at that time our jaws were
much bigger than our head does this mean
that food was more important than
intelligence and as we can see from the
drawing the smell of our meal was very
important too we can't blame cave people
we all love eating food just as much as
they do Charlie Brown back in our time
Charlie Brown was the hero of a comic
strip that lasted for 50 years it was so
popular that they even made a TV show
about him his friends and his dog Snoopy
but do you want to see what he looks
like in another world here is how Tim
O'Brien imagined him in the world of 3d
animation and by the look of it he
doesn't seem happy in this new universe
Charlie Brown has a sad look on his face
please find Snoopy so that he can give
him a hug it is impossible to be unhappy
when a dog is by your side Mario Bros
did you know that our favorite video
game character is also part of not one
but many TV shows and movies this is why
he deserves a place on our list Mario
was reimagined as a real-life character
by pixel ooh
except for his enormous nose and huge
eyes this one looks realistic and we
have to say that this mustache is still
really impressive
we can't wait for Mario and his brother
Luigi to save our world
someone will just have to tell him that
he can't jump into paintings as he
didn't Peach's castle
we don't want Mario to hurt himself by
running into a wall Bart Simpson we
can't stop looking at these weird
artworks inspired by The Simpsons so
here is one last one Bart Simpson was
recreated with 3d animation and once
again we wish he could stay in the
cartoon universe because he looks so out
of this world the weirdest thing is
probably that he has huge lips instead
of a chin but you would have liked to
see him with his original color did you
know that the characters from The
Simpsons are yellow so we can easily
know that we are watching the show when
we're flipping through the channels this
is the only thing missing in this
amazingly weird artwork and that's it
for 20 cartoon characters reimagined as
3d animations like this video if any of
these creations surprised you but if
your favorite cartoon character is
missing from our list don't forget to
tell us in the comments below and if you
can't get enough of cartoon characters
make sure you watch 10 kids reimagined
as people thanks for watching bye bye
[Music]